great feed cooking skills one through
ten i
never tried pete's food it's a zero not
every one of us has the same
big three expenses in our monthly budget
housing
transportation and food and beverage so
valuetainment rolled down to the south
beach wine and food festival
to see if people know how much they're
actually spending on their food and
drinks each month
let's talk money
all we talk is money where are you from
well we're local
so this is an exciting event from
pittsburgh virginia louisville kentucky
i'm from atlanta minneapolis charlotte
seattle memphis tennessee so what brings
you out here today food and wine you
know
i'm a cook so i want to taste the food
with the wine you're looking to have a
good time you're going to do more eating
or drinking today drinking
she's ready for a drink how much you
spend in general on food and drinks each
month
i'd say almost a thousand bucks a month
at least 500 bucks a month
i think when you go outside sometimes
you budget yourself a little bit more
but once you stay at home i mean you can
get a much better bottle of wine much
better whiskey at home that way you
go outside four or five hundred bucks a
month okay how about you dollar amount
how much you spend it
like a thousand a month fifty dollars a
week twenty two hundred dollars
twenty two hundred because we meal prop
what stuff you do what's it called
i forget she won't respond she forgets
but it's good i have a baby daddy
and i get food stamps so i don't spend
any money
oh we got some food stamped y'all read
your cooking skills one through ten
oh a solid nine solid niner rate his oh
his
he makes really good greek food he's a
ten eleven
eleven lucky man right here she's about
an eight eight and a half
bro come on you know i throw it down
rate pete's cooking skills one through
ten
i never tried pete's food pizza zero not
not applica
not applicable negative negative pete
right here
we gotta teach your friend how to cook
what's going on here nope can't cook
your wildest night out how much did you
spend over a hundred bucks at least
decay
at least at least a thousand yeah yeah
easy probably 150 to 200
a night i can't disclose that
information bro
would you guys say you eat in or eat out
more i eat in a lot
50 50 minutes yeah we eat out more i
mean we work so much but we don't get
that much time to go out so we tend to
entertain at the house
how often do you guys go out hit the bar
hit the scene hit the club how often
probably like three times a month at
home not off enough pandemic is made up
kind of different
it just sucks everywhere once a week
maybe every other week on the weekends
two three times a week
four days out of seven four days out of
seven you're you're a party guy
yeah well you know you gotta balance it
all out like an average maybe
two times a week but not not every week
so are you a weekend warrior
sometimes you're going hard on the
weekends you got to okay you got to you
ever made it rain in a club
yes sir why would i not why would i go
to the club last question give us your
best piece of advice for the people at
home how they can
save that money when it comes to eating
and drinking best piece of advice
make your drinks before you go out and
if you're gonna have a good time you're
gonna spend some money man eat at home
buy groceries stay at home buy good
ingredients
a good bottle of wine save
they don't know what to say they don't
know how to save money we tend to eat
breakfast and lunch at home dinner's the
big
spend stand at the bar wait til a guy
walks up to him run
stack it save it forget about it don't
spend it you just spend it at the shrimp
club
two bands you gotta stack the spin you
know what i'm saying definitely meal
prep
manage your money or you can damn near
be broke and always go out like me with
a kid
you know you just go to the liquor store
get your little paint on something
and then just make your drink get you a
little cooler and just walk down and
just drink up
before you hit the spots cause you know
they about six dollars yeah
damn they're a drink so just be careful
just gotta make more money
okay there it is all right this is
probably our craziest interview of the
day
we got two sets of twins so how did this
all come about how did you guys meet so
you said you're twins
we're twins we can get together you tell
your friends to get with my friends we
can be friends
and we can do this every night take it
slow guys take it slow we don't need
twins having more twins and then you
take it slow if you're going out and
you're drinking
how often do you get a guy to pay for
you and then just kind of give him the
peace sign afterwards
yeah like we try to every time that's
the tip
yeah we're girls so it's easier
sometimes you get free drinks here and
there
tell us about that what does it mean to
be a girl when you go out drinking you
got a drink and you run
okay i don't think that's the case i
feel like i always end up paying for
myself though
people and i end up paying for myself
either way even if they have a lot of
money so i don't give a [ __ ]
i i have i have money of my own i don't
really need a man
so after eating drinking and talking to
people all day here's my conclusion
some people know how much they're
spending each month on their f b
expenses but the majority of people
don't experts recommend keeping it at 10
to 15 percent of your budget
so before you piss all your money away
save that money